- I'm so all-in entrepreneur
I prefer the pain.
I love the climb.
To me the setback is exciting.
I love when
something goes wrong.
It's where I shine the most.
But that's not for everybody.
Right? I mean it could be
very difficult and when
you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and
all the other things
it can get real nasty.
To me, the way I handle
things even in the few rare
days when I really struggle,
I take a real step back
and make pretend that
somebody called me
and told me that my
mother or daughter
were killed.
and I know that's very dark.
And I apologize but
it's really what I do.
I literally am able to
at my deepest most struggling
moment within business,
take a step back and
remind myself that I could
make a drillion dollars
tomorrow on Bitcoin
and if something bad happened
to the people I love the most
that it would mean nothing.
And it very consistently
re-wires me very quickly.
I just put business
in perspective.
At the end of the day,
it's money, for me,
its not really money,
it's my legacy so I get hurt
by it a little bit more.
I put it in perspective.
It's money. And you know what?
Up until I had a daughter,
even while I was married,
up until when I had
Misha four years ago
I secretly wanted to
lose all my money.
I had this weird, twisted
dark fantasy of losing
everything just to rise
again like a phoenix
and remind you
mother fuckers.
(laughter)